banking stocks have tumbled on Monday as
initial relief about the rescue of
Credit Suisse has given way to new
worries about big bank's debt UBS shows
that down 12 as it agreed to buy
troubled rival Credit Suisse which has
seen its shares nosedive 62 UBS is
paying 3.2 billion dollars to buy the
bank and a state brokered deal the
government says the deal is the best
solution to restore confidence in the
sector
the bankruptcy of a global
systematically important bank would have
caused irreparable economic turmoil in
Switzerland and throughout the world for
this reason Switzerland had to take the
responsibilities Beyond its own borders
these efforts have paid off the federal
council is convinced that UBS takeover
of credit Swiss has laid the foundations
for greater stability both in
Switzerland and internationally
we're going to cross to Neve Barker now
who's live for us in London we're in the
first few hours after this deal was
announced Eve what's the reaction been
so far
overall you can almost hear the
collective sigh of relief here in the in
the city of London there is a real
feeling that a major Financial
catastrophe has potentially been averted
we've heard from the bank of England
saying that they uh have had their
confidence restore that things are
strong and working very well there
similar kind of words from the U.S
treasury and the European Central Bank
as well who would have thought it you
know two massive banking beer moths now
becoming one a company that will
whatever it ends up being called uh will
be worth something like 1.6 trillion
dollars uh going forward we reported
there of course about the fallen in
share prices there isn't I believe that
much concern about that despite the fact
the Credit Suisse has seen those share
prices fall something like 62 percent
its biggest fall ever the belief is that
simply the Market's driving the prices
down to what UBS believes that they're
worth the question is whether they
continue to fall or remain low while
this takeover starts to bed in a similar
kind of thing for UBS as well they were
down as you said about 12 percent the
hope is that that will stabilize there
is however a big question about what
happens to the people that work at
Credit Suisse and UBS 5 000 workers at
credit Swiss 6 200 uh UBS behind me we
know that UBS wants to streamline its
activities going forward it wants to
make what was what was left over of
credits where it's a little bit less
risk uh a more risk-averse rather and
whether that means cutting back jobs
well there's still very much a big
question mark over that but of course
the ball the feeling is that this has
averted a major instability in the
financial Hearts like London and other
centers across Europe as well Neve thank
you very much indeed that's Neil Barker
talking to us from London
well Credit Suisse isn't just one of
Switzerland's largest banks is also
classified as a globally systemically
important Bank by the financial
stability board their manages around 1.3
trillion dollars around the world its
profits dropped significantly in 2022
falling nearly 8 billion dollars after
losing 2 billion in 2021. its shares
have been in short decline since 2021
they've now lost more than 95 percent of
their value in the past five years
investors took their money elsewhere
last week when the bank's main
shareholder refused to offer financial
help after that even a 54 billion dollar
Lifeline from Switzerland's Central Bank
couldn't stem that pessimism and that
has left the buyout solution once UBS
acquires Credit Suisse it's going to
have access to more than five trillion
dollars in assets well Karen Alexander
is chair for international Commerce and
financial law at the University of
Zurich he's joining us now live from
there so thank you very much indeed for
being them with us I want to ask you
first of all about the the the share
movements that that we've seen as Neve
was suggesting there
um there is possibility this is just a
market
um Readjustment but how much of it is
down to our Readjustment and how much of
it is down to genuine concern about the
possible ramifications of this
well I think more of it has to do with
the concern for the ramifications of
this uh forced bailout that has taken
place over the weekend it was Crisis
management uh done over a short period
of time it's created much investor
uncertainty uh shareholder rights and
UBS have been suspended they weren't
given the right to approve the deal or
not also the treatment of bondholders
has been disregarded the finma the
regulator in Switzerland has imposed 16
billion francs and losses on bondholders
so this has created uncertainty and
volatility in the bot in the bank bond
market this morning so I'm afraid that
this is not just a blip this this Market
uncertainty it's going to probably get
worse so a lot of financial institutions
around the world are anxious to to kind
of calm down any pessimism to say that
the problem has been solved but looking
at this deal what's your interpretation
of who loses out the most from this
well Switzerland as a country has
suffered a damaging blow to its
reputation for Prudence stability and
fiscal management
also uh this is this failure you might
say of credit Swiss having to be taken
over by UBS is another example where not
only weak corporate governance accredit
Swiss caused the problem but also there
was weak regulation by the Swiss
regulatory authorities which made the
situation worse and now it has created a
crisis from that we all now hope can be
contained in the future the the bank
does have a history of problems does I'm
just reading here back in 2014 it
pleaded guilty to allowing U.S clients
to evade taxes back in 2020 is chief
executive resigned because of a
corporate Espionage scandals there's
been a storm of negative publicity
generally just because you at UBS has
bought Credit Suisse doesn't not
necessarily mean that the problems
Credit Suisse have been solved does it
no it doesn't uh for risk management and
weak governance practices have been uh
endemic at credit Swiss over the last
eight nine years and even as late as
December 2022 the chairman of credit
sources board told the market that the
and that the that the outflows that had
credit Swiss had been experiencing the
outflows of money from the bank had been
reversed and that they were getting
inflows when in fact it was completely
false what he said it was a false
statement and so I think investors have
a right to be concerned and that's why
there's continued Market volatility
going on
really interesting to get your thoughts
on this Karen Alexander we appreciate
you being with us and I'll do zero thank
you very much indeed
thank you